today I want to go over the top three
ways you can boost your testosterone the
first way you can increase your
testosterone is to make sure that you
are sleeping properly the majority of
your testosterone is produced during the
REM stage of sleep this means that
anything that interferes with your sleep
can negatively impact your levels the
second best way to increase your
testosterone is to work out a study
conducted in 1983 found that
testosterone levels of men increased by
21 right after a workout the best thing
to do is to lift heavy weights using
compound exercises this includes
exercises like squats and bench press
and finally a study was conducted by the
University of Queensland in 2010 they
sent researchers to a skatepark to
interview and record 96 male
skateboarders doing tricks afterwards
they took saliva samples to measure
their testosterone levels the study
found that skateboarders were being
filmed by female researchers had a
whopping 30 percent higher level of
testosterone than those who are being
filmed by male researchers which
suggests that being around and
performing in front of potential mates
drastically increases your testosterone
levels